mom-to-be katy perry moving out of the
country
the very pregnant pop star bared her
baby bump while busting some high-energy
moves to the viral
friday dance song beside her and
orlando's moving car
until she ran out of gas
hello internet how's everybody
bloom popped up again on katie's smile
sunday's live stream
shirt on this time after giving a new
interview saying they could temporarily
move to australia
after the birth quote if we were to do a
sabbatical it would definitely be there
katie revealed their baby girl is coming
soon this week
there has been a shift that means baby
cat
is preparing 45 extra pounds
that's right i'm large i'm marge i'm
still in charge
i'll snap back whenever i need to but
i'm not like worried about it
now to kim and kanye repairing things on
a family vacay
the west both looked relaxed exiting a
private jet in miami with her kids on
sunday
an eyewitness tells e.t kim seemed fine
and not worried at all
the kids were having a great time check
out north and those fuzzy slippers
carrying a bag of candy the family is
back in the u.s after spending seven
days in the dominican republic
a source tells e.t they're continuing
their vacation and want to work on
saving their marriage
taking time off the grid until they have
things figured out
this after a tense few weeks that
included kanye tweeting about
possible divorce just like katy perry
kanye shared this dancing video with
daughter north from the trip
it's saturday sunday
as for his run for president that's
still on
in a new interview with forbes which was
done over text
kanye didn't deny he hopes to take away
votes from biden and help trump
his response i'm not going to argue with
you jesus is king
and finally justin hardly slammed as
this divorce drama plays out on his exit
show
um i found out
because he text me that we were filed
christelle souza's claims fired up fans
watching season three
of selling sunset this weekend when one
viewer tweeted
justin hartley texted chrishell that he
was divorcing her
stouse replied with this gif of jordan
peel sweating profusely
caption me trying to keep it classy and
not like your tweet
one day we'll look back at this and
laugh i don't know hopefully
chrishell later defended justin posting
quote some of you are attacking a
certain person and defending me
i hate feeling like someone is getting
bullied i just hope you can keep the
passion but
maybe minus the vitriol do you feel like
you've had time to reflect about your
personal life the quarantine has given a
little you a little more time i think
given us all a little more time to sit
there and really
you know analyze i really i treat people
the way i want to be treated